so here's a scenario you're pretty
awkward definitely not the best of the
ladies but that's not for the lack of
trying
just when you think your luck is never
gonna change you notice your new
neighbor who also happens to be the most
attractive girl that you've ever seen so
you then do something completely out of
character you introduce yourself and
offer to show her around the
neighborhood and somehow things go
really and really well she even invites
you over to her place later that evening
you begin to wonder whether your
terrible luck with the ladies is finally
changing is this the one sadly the
answer is no no your luck is definitely
not changing and no she's definitely not
the one she turns out to be another
manny to inspire a woman and you just
happened to be her next meal for those
who still haven't guessed from the intro
or even read the title
today's video is indeed on the jaw
Goomer the man-eating spiders of
Japanese folklore so if you do have a
fear of spiders then I guess I'll be
seeing you in the next video
the jaraguá more another Japanese yokai
that take the form of a spider but they
have been known to change your
appearance to a more seductive woman
when it's time to feed a diet that
consists mostly of young men the name
Dragoon mo translates to mean entangling
bride which of course refers to the way
they entangle their prey in their web
but its name originally was thought to
mean a [ __ ] spider so take from that
what you will
in Japan spiders are thought to possess
supernatural powers but only certain
species the golden orb weaver was
believed to be the most common form for
the duralumin the size of these spiders
varies to quite a ridiculous extent
being anywhere from a few centimeters
long to large enough to kill a grown man
the old Weaver's were particularly known
for their vibrant colors their large
size and the very strong webs that they
weave
oddly enough the golden orb weaver isn't
too different from a regular spider
until it reaches a certain age and that
age happens to be 400 years old until
then they spend most of their time in
solidarity in places you'd expect to
find a spider so everywhere
once they reach 400 years old the old
Weaver gains its magical powers and
essentially becomes a jaw of normal they
developed the ability to transform any
shape-shift into a beautiful woman and
it's in this form that they deceive and
seduce young men
if the Jataka more often described as
having a cold heart and feeding no
remorse for those they murder to them
humans are no different to an insect
just another victim to feed on their
favorite meal of course being young
handsome men during the Edo period there
were stories of beautiful women Lauren
men into abandoned and secluded shacks
where they would play a Japanese
instrument known as a beaver the sound
of the instrument would distract and set
the victim into a deep trance and that's
when the Giacomo would strike wrapping
him in her silk thread until she was
hungry this freshness however isn't just
as simple as catching a man and killing
him the Joe legume would take pleasure
in consumed in their meal injecting
their victim of a venom that slowly
weakens them allowing the derocker
motive really savor their meal while
there are fortune of victims are
sentenced to a long and painful death
they can be found all throughout the
forest the caves and the dark and
secluded places of Japan except for in
Hokkaido the reason why I've yet to find
but maybe Hokkaido was just the
arachnophobia part of Japan that just
wasn't having any of that killer spider
woman nonsense but I'm sure those
natives Japan are those who are more
informed in regards to the traditions
and superstitions found in Hokkaido
we'll be able to let us know in the
comments section we did mention that
they develop a variety of powers and the
Daruma are extremely cunning capable of
concealing themselves for hundreds of
years despite being in plain sight the
girl next door could be a jolly Gumo and
you likely never know as you may expect
they could also control other spiders
and it became fairly common for the
Jorah goomar to be depicted as a half
woman half spider creature accompanied
by hundreds if not thousands of spider
children now a tails of these children
vary from regular spiders to
fire-breathing lunatics who burn down
the houses of anyone who become
suspicious of their mother so be careful
who you go around accusing of being a
man-eating spider woman perhaps the most
famous story feature in rhetorical mode
is the tale of the Jordan George Gamow
the mistress of Jordan Falls a waterfall
in a city of Shizuka the story begins of
a man rest him by a waterfall when all
of a sudden he could feel his feet being
tied together by spider thread and he
was slowly being dragged down into the
water below in order to free himself he
cut the threads and tied them to a tree
the spiders were so strong that they
uprooted the tree and dragged it into
the water
eventually word would spread of the
incident and the jordan waterfall was
abandoned by the villages for fear of
what lived there and there was one
however who did venture to the waterfall
completely unaware of the Jordan Duram
oh and the stories of the surrounding
area the man was a lumberjack from out
of town and so he began chopping wood
until he eventually dropped his axe into
the water
he'd over on to retrieve it but when he
eventually resurfaced unable to find his
axe standing there in front of him was a
beautiful young woman he also noticed
that his axe had been returned to him
the woman made the man swear that he
wouldn't tell anyone about her and so he
kept the secret for as long as he could
one day the man had a little too much to
drink and he began to tell the story of
the beautiful woman by the waterfall
once he had told the story he fell into
a deep slumber never to awaken again
descendants certainly does raise some
questions and for me personally it made
me wonder what else the Daruma were
capable of do they have some kind of
power over those who swear an oath to
them is their secret or their promise
binding the story of the jaraguá man the
lumberjack does seem to have many
different variations most of which
seemed to be about the man fallen in
love of the woman only to later realize
that he's slowly getting weaker and
weaker
he eventually seeks help from a monk who
tells him that the woman is evil and
that he should stay away which of course
is advice that he doesn't listen to
regardless of the details the story
always seems to end in the exact same
way with a man fallen into a deep
slumber never to awake again the
geronimo are a yokai that we can easily
brand as evil as their actions are quite
cold and calculated bordering on
vindictive but at times they also just
act like a spider so whether it's just
in their nature to behave that way
or whether they are an evil entity I
guess it's down to your own
interpretation feel free to share your
thoughts and ideas with me in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
wishing you all a very happy and
exciting new year
[Music]